Good night, Edith.
Good night, Margo.
Hold your horses.
Who are you texting?
My friend Avery.
Avery, Avery?
Is that a girl's name or a boy's name?
Does it matter?
No, no, it doesn't matter unless it's a boy!
I know what makes you a boy.
You do?
Your bald head.
Oh, yes.
Sometimes I stare at it and imagine a little chick popping out.
Good night, Agnes.
Never get older.
Mr. Gru?
Agent Lucy Wilde of the Anti-Villain League.
You're gonna have to come with me.
Oh, sorry, I... Freeze Ray!
You know, you really should announce your weapons after you fire them.
For example, Lipstick Taser!
Get in there.
Hey! What the...
We are the Anti-Villain League, dedicated to fighting crime on a global scale.
A new villain has surfaced.
You know how a villain thinks, that's why we brought you here.
Pins and needles.
I am the league's director, Silas Ramsbottom.
Bottom!
Hilarious.
Are you really gonna save the world?
That's right, baby!
Gru is back in the game with cool cars, gadgets and weapons.